et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 9 juillet en ce début
d'été l'inquiétude monte l'augmentation
des contaminations au kobus 19 et
notamment l'apparition de plus en plus
fréquente du variant delta fait craindre
à une quatrième vague pour fin juillet
pour en parler notre invité mario chin
ali directrice départementale yvelines
de l' agence régionale de santé du sport
ensuite les jo 2024 approche et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait partie
des lieux haute la colline d'elancourt
accueillera les épreuves de vtt de
nombreux aménagements y sont prévues
pour la compétition mais aussi pour
après côté loisirs enfin cette semaine
avec cellier agathe son goût nous irons
à la fête des loges dans la forêt de
saint germain en laye et nous vous
proposerons aussi des idées d'activités
organisées par les mairies yvelinoise
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre une
reprise épidémique inquiète en ce début
de vacances scolaires d'été une
inquiétude d'autant plus forte que le
variant delta est désormais bien
implanté en île de france pour en parler
nous accueillons marion tina ly bonsoir
alors vous êtes la directrice
départementale de l'agencé régionale de
santé donc dans les yvelines
d'abord un point sur la situation
épidémique dans les yvelines
dans le département le taux d'incidence
est actuellement plutôt bas à 39
quand la moyenne française et pourtant
elle a 25 selon le site qu'ovide tracker
point fr ce qui signifie que le nombre
de cas est de 39 sur les sept derniers
jours pour 100000 habitants pour rappel
le seuil d'alerté à 50
les contaminations sont elles en hausse
par rapport à la semaine dernière et
outre cette hausse de contamination
c'est surtout la part du variant delta
qui inquiètent toujours selon koffi de
traqueur point fr environ 60% des
contaminations dans les yvelines
porterait la trace de ce variant ce sont
des chiffres qui vous inquiète
marginalise oui tout à fait sembler chef
toulousain cap effectivement vous
préciser les inspecteurs épidémiologique
en hausse
il augmente assez considérablement assez
rapidement par rapport à la semaine
passée et la semaine encore avant et il
augmente surtout sur les tranches d'âge
des 20 30 ans et qu'il reste stable pour
la population de plus de 65 ans et donc
effectivement c'est quelque chose qu'on
suit de près vous le dites également les
pcr crible et représente aujourd'hui la
part du variant dans les pc recrues de
l'er présenté aujourd'hui au niveau
régional plus de 52%
de pcr avec du variant donc
effectivement c'est des chiffres qu'on
surveille de près parce que c'est pareil
en qui va vite et beaucoup plus vite que
le variant britanniques mais également
que le virus initial qu'on connaissait
justement que ce à quoi ses spécificités
et ses variantes delta que par rapport
aux combis de classiques ou britannico
plusieurs variants qu'on a pu avoir
et bien en fait c'est sa vitesse de
circulation que les 60 à 80% deux fois
plus rapide que le variant britannique
et donc du coup non
on surveille vraiment un petit démarrage
d'épidémies qui pourraient prendre une
ampleur beaucoup plus importante et très
rapidement sûrement avec la période
estivale qui a démarré avec beaucoup
moins de restrictions la levée notamment
de l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur par exemple si la hausse des
contaminants pour celui-ci la part du
variant delta également s'agrandit et
les plans d'action en particulier dans
les yvelines
le plan d'action pour démarrer est quand
même la vaccination parce que en fait
qu'avec un parcours vaccinale complet
donc avec deux injections et bien du
coup on à moindre risque alors d'abord
de contracter le coc vide mais surtout
d'en faire des formes graves et donc
c'est pour ça que au niveau national au
niveau régional et départemental
il est demandé qu'on puisse accélérer
maintenir cette vaccination soit en
centre de vaccination mais aussi sur des
opérations exceptionnelles qu'on va
réaliser tout l'été au plus près de la
population pour aller rencontrer cette
population qui n'est pas encore vaccinés
pour des raisons de praticité d'accès à
la vaccination pour des raisons
d'organisation ou encore des raisons un
peu de
dernier élément à convaincre et donc et
donc du coup on organise ces
vaccinations au plus près de la
population
parce que ça reste quand même le plan
d'actions prioritaires et ensuite
évidemment l'autre plan d'action c'est
les dépistages donc là aussi on va
maintenir une capacité dépistage forte
durant tout l'été avec nos centres de
dépistage qui reste ouvert tout l'été
et puis également des opérations ce
qu'on appelle barnum tout en un à la
fois avec du dépistage à la fois avec de
la vaccination pour permettre de
circonscrire l'épidémie
alors l'été on profite on s'est du coup
vous parliez des vaccinations de
dépistage il ya aussi les gestes
barrières qu'il faut j'imagine
poursuivre nous en tant que citoyen
chacun de son côté
évidemment vous avez entièrement raison
il vaut mieux continuer à porter le
masque quand vous êtes en extérieur et
que vous voyez que vous êtes en un dans
une zone qui est assez dense en terme de
population
il faut évidemment continuer à porter le
masque en intérieur et puis les gestes
barrière utilisait du gel
hydroalcoolique en apparence a plus trop
le faire donc il faut le refaire et donc
conserver toutes les bons acquis qu'on a
eues durant ces 18 derniers mois
alors vous avez évoqué la vaccination
justement et cette accélération que le
gouvernement souhaite on écoute
justement le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire il était en déplacement
jeudi 8 juillet à versailles
il s'est exprimé sur la possibilité
d'une obligation de la vaccination
on a tout autour de nous des amis
restaurateurs qui viennent de redémarrer
on n'a pas envie qu'il soit obligé de
refermer dans quelques semaines on a
toujours de nous des salariés qu'on
retrouvait leur emploi dans des magasins
dans les commerces des magasins
d'habillement par exemple dans des
hôtels on n'a pas envie que à nouveau et
des contraintes sanitaires sont vraiment
au nom de toutes ces personnes qui
pendant 14 mois ont subi la crise
sanitaire de manière très dure je
souhaite que chacun se fasse vacciner
je souhaite pas que la vaccination
devienne obligatoire pour tous les
français mais je souhaite qu'il y ait
une obligation pour ceux qui sont en
contact des personnes les plus fragiles
c'est à dire des soignantes
quand vous êtes au contact de personnes
très âgées des personnes malades
personnes fragiles je pense que la
responsabilité commande que vous fassiez
vacciner alors on l'a entendu pas de
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français pour le moment mais une
obligation possible obligatoirement pour
les soignants si les pistes envisagées
marushin ali même au sein de l'agencé
régionale de santé
alors ça c'est pas quelque chose du tout
qui défilent au niveau de la langue
régionale de santé ars est la compétence
du gouvernement et donc on va on va voir
comment le gouvernement se positionnera
mais effectivement c'est dans cette
piste de réflexion
ce sera à vous le mettez en place tout
de même alors ça sera pas nécessairement
à nous de le mettre en place on mettra
un dispositif dont m on applique le
dispositif qui est déjà existants après
on verra s'il ya une obligation
vaccinale où les gens pourront se faire
vacciner soit 6 et leurs médecins
traitants soient ensemble de vaccination
nous le dispositif de vaccination il est
en place et il est toujours en cours et
l'appât s'arrête et de tout tout de
suite et qui est obligations pas
obligation vaccinale ça va rien changer
dans notre organisation est justement un
dernier mot sur les centres de
vaccination vous l'avez dit plusieurs
fermetures de centres je pense chatou
rambouillet bonnières sur seine
mais il y en a qui restent ouverts
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
petit peu ce qui reste ouvert cet été
eh bien écoutez en sur notre 1830 a
effectivement trois centres qui vont
fermer là durant l'été et les 15 autres
vont donc rester ouverts certains vont
fermer une semaine deux semaines voir
quelques uns trois semaines durant les
congés mais là des périodes alternatif
on puisse assurer une continuité
d'activité
puis vous avez quatre centres qui eux
restent ouverts tout l'été qui ne ferme
pas du tout donc à saint quentin le
vélodrome à saint-germain-en-laye mantes
la jolie
et puis le centre sans rendez vous allez
des visiteuses qui a été ouvert à la mi
juin
merci mal en chine ali je le rappelle
vous êtes directrice départementale de
l'agencé régionale de santé dans les
yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour ce 7,8
week end
[Applaudissements]
parlons sport à présent les jo de 2024
approche et saint-quentin-en-yvelines
fait partie des lieux haute la colline
d'elancourt accueillera les épreuves de
vtt de nombreux aménagements ils sont
prévues pour la compétition mais aussi
pour après les détails avec astrid
bergère et juliette prigent d'ici 2024
la colline d'elancourt va changer
d'apparence le lieu accueillera les
épreuves de vtt pour les jeux olympiques
un projet ambitieux pour cet espace
aujourd'hui peu utilisés allaient
recouverte essentiellement d'arbres qui
ont poussé tout seul et une végétation à
la fois luxuriante mais également
sauvage on a un certain nombre de
plantes invasives un hématome à sauvages
qu'ils se trompaient au fil des années
par le fait que des tétons sont passés
des gens vélo et parfois malheureusement
des gens également en moto en quad qui
sont pas les bienvenues mais qui utilise
cette colline et elle est aujourd'hui
essentiel bourg ouvertes simplement la
probable les différentes phases du
projet ont été annoncés lors d'une
réunion publique en ligne mercredi 7
juillet pendant la compétition tente
tribunes et gradins accueilleront les
équipes sportives technique et pour
l'après 2024 des aménagements sont
prévus
j'ai des espaces de détente et de
promenade pour les familles un dieu
ouverts et accessibles pour les pour les
piétons pour les familles pour les
parents les enfants à l'ensemble des
usagers possible renforcer la pratique
de la course à pied en complément de des
circuits de détente et de promenade
développer une offre de vtt complète et
adaptée à tous on va conserver la piste
vtt olympique avec un rayonnement
sportif international qui va nous
permettre de réorganiser par la suite
d'éventuels événements internationaux
autre point important la préservation de
l'environnement naturel de la colline on
va complètement transformer cette
colline la vente du rap point de vue de
l'environnement puisque les arbres
seront plantés sur les arbres spécifique
avec pays étudiés pour vivre à cet
endroit là qui sont des coexister dans
les milieux et également qui sera
étudiée pour qu' un certain nombre
d'espèces qui vit aujourd'hui sa colline
voir qu'ils ont disparu puisque venir y
revivre une concertation est prévue du
20 septembre au 20 octobre 2021 objectif
informer le public et recueillir les
avis sur les caractéristiques du projet
retour en 78 secondes sur l'actualité de
la semaine dans les yvelines avec
bixente mais rien senti stevan les
élèves de terminale ont reçu leurs
résultats au baccalauréat éditions 2000
21 89 6 % des étudiants de l'académie de
versailles ont réussi leurs épreuves
sans passer par la case rattrapage pour
les autres la seconde chance avait lieu
du mercredi 7 à ce vendredi 9 juillet
résultats définitifs à suivre très
prochainement
la vaccination se poursuit dans les
yvelines tout au long de l'été
quatre centres resteront ouverts pour la
période estivale dans la crainte d'une
nouvelle vague est liée aux vaillants
dette
des mesures ont été prises pour
permettre la vaccination du plus grand
nombre
le délai entre deux injections et
dorénavant situés sur une fourchette
entre 21 et 40 9 jours des plages
d'ouverture des centres ont été étendues
et il n'est plus nécessaire de prendre
rendez vous au préalable
depuis deux semaines les jeunes se
réunissent par centaines le week end sur
la place du marché de versailles pour
des rassemblements appelé soirée projet
x problème c'est soirée dégénère souvent
jusqu'à se transformer en affrontements
entre bandes ce qui suscite l'inquiétude
des riverains et commerçants
pas d'informations pour le moment autour
d'une troisième soirée pour ce week end
france miniature fête ses 30 ans le parc
aux 117 monuments nationaux situés à
elancourt attire depuis sa création plus
de deux cent mille visiteurs par an pour
son anniversaire le parc offre la visite
à toutes les personnes qui partagent sa
date de naissance
l'année 1990 enfin du football alors que
l'euro se termine ce dimanche côté
transferts un yvelinois singh à
l'olympique de marseille
matteo guendouzi jeune international
français de 22 ans originaire de poissy
rejoint le club phocéen sous forme de
prêt avec une obligation d'achat estimée
à 11 millions d'euros
[Musique]
après une semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi c'est lié à 400 go
vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons vous emmener à
la fête des loges après une annulation
en 2001
cette fête traditionnelle à
saint-germain-en-laye revient pour une
360 huitième édition les 180 attractions
sont installés prête à accueillir
plusieurs milliers de visiteurs durant
tout l'été
bixente mais rien senti stebel y est
allé pour nous comme un air
d'inauguration pour les 180 attractions
de la fête des loges après deux ans
d'absence
un rendez vous qui a l'instinct d'un
bancables pour de nombreux visiteurs sa
marque était en fait le début de la fête
des loges et du coup l'année dernière
comme s'est pas ouvert ma passion ne pas
avoir été en fait c'est eux qui nous
marque le début des vacances en famille
confie un défilé festif a été organisée
pour célébrer cette réouverture des
réjouissances marque du soulagement des
organisateurs
après une édition 2009 un anonyme
envoyée par le bout du tunnel exactement
donc c'est vrai que là de coude avoir eu
assez de sortie de crise en tout cas et
pouvoir redémarrer en plus par la fête
des loges qui est l'une des foires les
plus familial que je connaisse en juin
de 1 en tout cas c'était super beaucoup
de bonheur beaucoup de plaisir on a vécu
quand même voilà seize mois 18 mois
compliqués l'année dernière ça avait été
terrible que de prendre la décision je
crois qu'aucun maire avant n'avait eu à
prendre cette décision que d'annuler la
fête des loges pendant les prochaines
semaines jeunes les familles pourront
trouver leur bonheur au milieu des autos
tamponneuses de la pêche aux canards ou
encore des nombreux manèges à sensations
fortes
il convient plutôt pour les petits lots
on a on a des enfants dont un quart en
bas âge donc on fait on fait plutôt
plutôt calme et bon ça c'est agréable
aussi y'a pleins pleins de jeux sympas
une fête qui aura attendu après le 30
juin et la levée des restrictions du
nombre de visiteurs pour ouvrir mais ces
retrouvailles avec le public se
prolongeront en musique tous les soirs
sans exception jusqu'au 15 août prochain
une traversée de 100 m à 20 mètres de
haut samedi 20 juillet à 16 heures
tatiana mossot bonga funambules de la
compagnie bassinga va réaliser l'exploit
d'une traversée de l'immeuble
edison jusqu'à la bibliothèque
universitaire de saint quentin en
yvelines au dessus de la perspective de
marta pan à guyancourt avec bixente n'ai
ressenti steban et mélanie poké nous
avons rencontré la funambule et le
codirecteur artistique et technique pour
parler de ce spectacle nous sommes à
guyancourt sur le toit de la
bibliothèque universitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines en compagnie de
tatiana mossot bon gars vont soir
bonsoir
vous êtes la funambule 1,2 ou
d'accompagner bassinga et yann mats
beaufort bonjour vous êtes directeur
technique et artistique de la compagnie
alors expliquez-moi peut-être tatiana
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra voir samedi et
bien samedi on va pouvoir voir un
spectacle funambule parce que je vais
traverser entre la bibliothèque
universitaire et le bâtiment edison
cette traversée funambule sera
accompagné par des musiciens en live
du coup guitare chant et saxophone et en
plus de ça sur le sur le trajet on aura
des cavaliers ti qui sont installés ces
des sortes de haubans qui empêche le
fils de bouger de gauche à droite et ses
cordes seront tenus par des habitants
mais justement on peut en parler
normalement vous il ya des habitants il
y aura 14 ans et ça normalement amateurs
qui viendront que c'était important de
faire participer aussi un peu le public
nous le nom bassinga ça vient du lingala
une langue qu'on part en centrafrique ou
qui veut dire corde au pluriel et nous
on a eu très tôt si comme lien comme
pont et on a envie de tisser des liens
avec des gens localement donc des fois
on a des musiciens qui se rajoute à nous
à nos musiciens
des fois c'est les cavales et east qui
viennent aider à stabiliser le fil alors
c'est de traverser un s'inscrit dans le
cadre des escapades événement le phare
de l'été de saint quentin en yvelines
alors combien de temps va durer à peu
près ce spectacle s'appelle les lignes
ouvertes ans et bientôt ils s'appellent
ligne ouverte ça va durer environ une
demi-heure après le timing on s'est
jamais véritablement parce que tout
dépendra de la météo de comment est ce
que je me sens sur le fil de tout un tas
de paramètres et c'est ça qu'on aime
bien c'est dans ce spectacle c'est qu'on
sait que c'est vivante c'est du
spectacle vivant et on doit s'adapter
dans l'instant donc
donc voilà je dirais une demi heure vous
en tant que directeur technique quelle
installation il doit y avoir pour que
tout se passe bien
eh bien il faut qu'on arrive à attendre
ce fils qui est tendu à 3 tonnes de
tension et donc il faut que les points
de la croche qu'on a créé résister à
cette tension là donc c'est une
réflexion en amont éventuellement des
calculs avec des ingénieurs des bureaux
d'études et donc là on vient de finir
les installations pour la partie ancrage
et l'attention de bordeaux fils et
demain on commence à mettre justement
c'est cavaletti ses fils de haubanage
sur le fil ce que vous êtes attaché à
tatiana sur cette traversée est est-ce
que c'est dangereux c'est le public se
pose cette question souvent
c'est pas dangereux c'est risqué j'ai
pas une longe de sécurité
j'ai pas quelque chose qui est harnaché
de monde un baudrier jusqu'au jusqu'au
fil ou un autre fils par contre sous mon
costume j'ai un baudrier et je peux
m'arrêter n'importe où sur le trajet
pour m'asseoir et m'accrocher si je sens
que je me sentais bien
si je sens qu'il ya trop de vent aussi
d'un coup il se met à pleuvoir donc
l'installation est pas aussi bien que ce
que ce qu'elle devrait donc à n'importe
quel moment je peux m'arrêter faire un
signe aux techniciens pour qu'il vienne
me chercher qu'il me descendre le
balancier aussi à son petit mousquetons
pour être accrochés pour pas qu'ils
tombent par terre
ce que vous pouvez nous parler un petit
peu de la compagnie c'est une compagnie
qu'on a monté en 2014 suite à un
événement qu'on a fait dans le village
où on habite maintenant et d'autres gens
de la compagnie aussi où on a installé
un premier fils et ce fils là il nous a
fait créer une compagnie qui vont à
nommer bassinga et au fur et à mesure
qu'elle se développe on voit que à côté
de l'aspect artistique pure sur le fil
on a aussi cet aspect de rencontre et de
travail avec les gens ça fait vraiment
partie des envies qu'on a et donc on va
vraiment à la rencontre et à la
recherche de la rencontre avec les gens
c'est impossible père important pour
nous de pouvoir rencontrer les habitants
d'une ville et pas faire je suis une
traversée qui est juste là pour un
événement mais une traversée qui
s'inscrit dans quelque chose d'un peu
plus grand en fait pour que ce soit
ouais pour qu'elle puisse se fondre dans
un des cas auraient pas justement être
là pour repartir
on a envie que ce fils il puisse encore
être matérialisé une fois qu'on est
parti et où il n'ya pas uniquement sept
funambules sur ce film les musiciens ils
ont autant d'importance dans ce projet
que la technique que les gens qui sont à
la médiation et toutes les rôles tout
les postes qu'on peut avoir dans la
compagnie et dans le public des cavales
et east aussi les musiciens
éventuellement qui se rajoute à la
compagnie tous ces gens là on veut les
mettre en valeur ils ont tous une place
mais merci beaucoup tatiana d'avoir été
nos invités et puis bien sûr dans ce
spectacle est à retrouver un samedi au
10 juillet il est réalisé par des
professionnels et donc attention à ne
pas le reproduire chez vous
les vacances ont commencé depuis
quelques jours déjà et les premiers
juillettistes sont déjà partis mais pour
ceux qui restent ici eu plusieurs
animations sont prévues puis ça a été
mal ressenti stevan bonsoir sort alors
vous allez nous parler du programme dans
les yvelines
oui c'est ça la saison estivale a aussi
débuté dans les yvelines
comme chaque année les communes ont
dévoilé leur programme d'été plein
d'activités de spectacles de loisirs et
je peux vous garantir célia que cet été
il y aura de l'animation et cela
commence dès ce week-end
oui avec de nombreux rendez-vous à
mantes la jolie par exemple avec une
journée entière d'animation ce samedi au
parc du domaine de la vallée stage de
tennis structures gonflables et même un
concert de la chanteuse sarah jade
seront proposés le soir
autre exemple à coignières qui propose
un panel d'activités du 10 au 18 juillet
ça s'appelle un été à coignières on
écoute didier fischer maire de la ville
pour nous en parler c'est un espace
d'animation pour les jeunes quoi ni rien
jusqu'à 17 ans à peu près c'est une
forme de petits villages vacances que
l'on met en place avec chalets buvette
l'implantation aussi de structures
gonflables pour les plus jeunes
et puis un espace d'animation de détente
avec celle long
tout ceci sera alimenté deux temps forts
comme la présence de poneys la
projection de la finale de l'euro et un
grand barbecue familial le samedi 17
juillet donc c'est jusqu'au 18 juillet
un pur coignières mais d'autres villes
le propose des activités tout au long de
l'été oui à manier les hameaux le
programme sports loisirs culture de cet
été et évadez-vous hamani est connu
c'est la deuxième édition de l'événement
qui a remplacé à la dernière le
traditionnel était en tongs qui ne
durait qu'une semaine comme à coignières
avec l'aco vie de la mairie a souhaité
proposer ce type d'occupation aux
habitants durant toute la période
estivale
une formule qui a été appréciée donc
renouveler roberto drapron adjoint au
maire nous présente les moments forts de
cette année on va avoir quatre temps
forts le dise le 13 le 16 et le 27 août
10 13 16 juillet et 27 août c'est sa
sueur sur des activités qui vont être
créés sur la totalité de notre ville de
magny les hameaux
avec des temps sur l'art la culture la
musique des initiations sportives aussi
donc quelque chose de vraiment génial
sur sur l'ensemble de manille pour nos
habitants
début des festivités dès ce week-end au
quartier du buisson et mardi 13 juillet
prochain avec le pique nique républicain
et il est bon de rappeler que toutes ces
activités aussi bien à magny les hameaux
ou encore à coignières sont entièrement
gratuites oui bien sûr à part les
petites collations et boissons gâteaux
tout est gratuit
c'est vraiment l'objectif des villes de
proposer de quoi se distraire savourer
l'été du mieux possible
même quand on ne part pas en vacances
par exemple je ne pourrais pas détailler
le programme de toutes les villes
malheureusement ça serait beaucoup trop
long mais vous pouvez facilement les
retrouver sur le site internet des
communes et les réseaux sociaux
merci beaucoup milité pour toutes ces
informations et pour finir cette page
vous dire je vous propose une idée
deux sorties pour une autre idée en tout
cas de sorties pour ce week end en forêt
de saint germain en laye une marche
commentée est organisée samedi 10
juillet de 14h30 à 17h un parcours de
6,5 km jalonné d'arbres remarquables
rendez vous à l'étoile des neuf routes
pour aborder des thèmes comme les
écosystèmes forestiers ou encore les
différentes espèces d'arbres
réservation obligatoire auprès de
l'office de tourisme intercommunal saint
germain boucles de seine et l'émission
continue avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez-vous en partenariat avec les
surligneurs on écoute vincent couronne
docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs
c'est l'été et à ceux qui s'apprêtent à
imposer à leurs enfants des devoirs de
vacances à ceux qui se disent qu'ils
n'ont pas droit à des vacances et qu'ils
ont le devoir de travailler à tout cela
jeudi détendez vous vous avez aussi des
droits
il y a quelques semaines emmanuel macron
et c'est ainsi en visite à nevers et
face à des étrangers sans papiers il
leur avait dit qu'ils devaient prendre
leur part dans l'intégration ne pas tout
attendre de la france et il a fini par
lâcher cette petite phrase vous avez des
devoirs avant d'avoir des droits avec
notre philosophe du droit maxence
christelle nous nous sommes bien
interrogé sur cette phrase le devoir tel
qu'il est utilisé un de l'homme dans le
langage ordinaire se rattache à la
philosophie morale
il faudrait que certaines choses soient
faites ont au contraire interdite pour
des raisons et des justifications qui
peuvent varier suivant les époques les
auteurs respecter ses parents par
exemple ou laisser les places assises
aux personnes âgées dans les transports
mais pour être juridiquement
contraignant un devoir moral doit être
transformés en obligations
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça eh bien on
n'a pas tout dit qu'elle existe des
devoirs sans droit des droits sans
devoirs dans sa déclaration
emmanuel macron semble dire que les
devoirs viennent avant les droits sauf
que et bien c'est pas toujours le cas
ainsi un meurtrier qui ne respectent pas
le devoir de ne pas ôter la vie n'en
perd pas pour autant ses droits à être
jugé par un tribunal impartial
un nourrisson n'a aucun devoir et
pourtant il possède de nombreux droits
il existe même des droits devoirs la
confusion en est que plus grande
et c'est l'exemple de la dignité humaine
tout le monde a le droit à ce que sa
dignité soit respecté mais chacun a le
devoir de respecter la dignité des
autres au final et je vous laisse avec
ses devoirs pour les vacances peut-on
imposer des devoirs avant les droits
vous avez tout l'été
c'était la dernière édition de votre
statut tweak haine pour cette saison et
ma dernière émission avec vous merci de
l'avoir suivi et merci pour cette année
la semaine prochaine place à l'été avec
une émission spéciale avec plein d'idées
pour cette période estivale dans les
yvelines
d'ici là passé une très bonne soirée un
très bon week-end et surtout un très bon
été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]